[Music]
you know what always bothers me about
this piece we start it and it shows that
picture of the back of me wearing a
sweat suit That's not me it is that yeah
and I would have gladly posed for a
second wearing a t-shirt but they got
like an intern and then put my head on
and it just bothers me that's not the
back of my neck no it isn't there's way
more freckles on your neck I mean that's
what you're talking about right yeah
sure
anyway let's look at these infobutton
little thingies for example I was
watching Undercover Boss the other day
it's watching that show people liked
that show and then I hit the little info
button is what it said it said a boss
thinks their employees are so stupid
they can't tell when someone's wearing a
wig yeah and I was watching diners
drive-ins and dives
yeah and then I hit the little info
button it said small business owners
have to feed a sentient toilet brush or
he'll never leave
Hey look at this one right here vinyl I
was watching vinyl I'm gonna hit the
info button and it said a show so close
to being cancelled they've already
turned up no nobody's ring closing
that's yeah it's ridiculous the flash
then we hit little button right here a
show about a guy that runs you like
running right though that fastest guy
can run house hunters you want the you
watch the show ID house hunters yeah
house hunters and then I hit the little
button said dramatic season finale in
which the house hunters become the house
[Applause]
Castle I was watching the show Castle I
love that show Castle then I hit the
button and it said enough cats walked
across remotes to keep this on the air
for
[Applause]
that's got me through some lean years
hey Chicago med that was watching
Chicago med yeah then I hit the button
instead from the makers of Chicago fire
and Chicago PD if you're an actor from
Chicago who can't get on one of these
shows it's time to hang it up American
ninja warriors I was watching American
ninja warriors yep and I hit the button
and it said today's American ninja
warriors and tomorrow's American Eagle
Managers watching Dateline you gotta
love date lines been around forever date
line yeah and then you hit the button it
says murder the one industry the Chinese
can't beat us at rosewood as watch the
show rosewood hit the button
I've been in the infographic button
writing business for over 17 years and I
gotta tell you this one's got me stumped
hit I'm just going with loose cannon
public defender
[Applause]
and finally the bachelorettes yeah whoo
bachelorette yeah and then I hit the
button and it said Trump supporters mate
[Applause]
you